là où ça bouge ne sommes à paris au
théâtre du rond point
juste quelques notes une rime idiot
ça n'a rien d'ordinaire un refrain tout
bête qui trotte dans la tête ça n'a rien
de vulgaire pardon
là pas plus chic qu'une chanson
populaire avec françois morel et et le
vinyle
ce que je trouve ça plus jolie de
montrer à vignes et de câlins car ces
désaccords et russes étaient fiers de
faire un vinyle c'est vrai à 33 tours
comme j'en ai acheté il ya 30 ans
quand je joue un spectacle dans le fond
je je joue au 18 petites pièces de
théâtre les unes derrière les autres que
je chante toi mais je sais de chez c'est
de vraiment chanter d'autant que j'ai
des bons musiciens avec moi et notamment
antoine soler on est à cette phase là je
pense de notre complicité notre travail
commun de pouvoir se permettre aussi
d'arriver là l'autre avec des bouts de
trucs sans avoir trouvé de faire du jeu
bord de l'eau douce est ce que ça ça
t'inspire quelque chose et puis voilà et
on essaie de décrire la chanson ensemble
la taille du général de gaulle avec 96
c'est ça enfin à mettre 87 à l'âge
adulte a alors donné il a fait un mètre
quarante sept comme tout le monde pour
la pour le mans mais oui le passage du
capiton et c'est quelque chose que je
n'aurais pas osé faire peut-être lui en
plus il ya 4 5 ans quand on écrivait des
chansons du précédent vous êtes et
progressif
au début des cris début le silence quand
ça disparaît comme par magie
on ne sait jamais pourquoi ça commence
eux
on ne sait pas plus pour passage guinée
au début du film
on dit on l'a cru
deux ans
on attrape ardue
on sait rien du tout passons
ça finit un peu
la green avis
villa villa villamil
j'ai la sensation que sur cet album là
votre voix et s'est affirmé et que vous
êtes passés de quelqu'un qui aime la
chanson à quelqu'un qui est complètement
jean theuret vous le dit un peu là
est-ce que vous avez conscience de ça
que ça y est cette fois ci quand album
là c'est françois morel oui je suis
chanteur je suis pas comédien chanteur
je suis champion je suis le dit pas
comme ça mais dans le fond c'est ce que
je ressens quand même un petit peu c'est
à dire je crois que je prends ça plus au
sérieux peut-être moi j'ai besoin de
temps alors j'ai mis un temps fou à dire
que j'étais comédien de jeu français de
romans ça peut-être un truc qu'on y va
doucement et on veut pas mais maintenant
et je pense va ça me fait plaisir ce que
vous me dites parce que si jamais si
jamais joué je vais prendre une copie de
2,2 du reportage et je le donnerais à
mon professeur de chant qui va être vite
dans sa faculté de guérisseur plus quand
vous écrivez vos parts et d'une émotion
ce n'est pour des fois où d'un mot oui
des fois ça peut partir d'un mot exigé
petit jésus par exemple si une fois
monté dans ma voiture et j'ai pensé
petit jésus tu m'as déçue giro ça c'est
un bon refrain
le malfrat mai
j'étais gent féminine
c'est ça et j'aime autant vous dire que
je suis fier de jouer au théâtre de caen
parce que c'est là que j'ai vu un
certain nombre de mes idoles et donc
cette fois là moi je serai sur la scène
êtes prévenus françois morel et thétys à
paris et bientôt il est de retour chez
lui en normandie avec un excellent jeune
je ne sais plus trop qui à dire les
peaux belle la vie
- 30 dans la tête
vulgaire
ensemble